so an incredible woman her name is Marcy
wheeler she lives in our great state
right down in Ann Arbor she is a
national blogger she blogs his empty
wheel and the next hurrah firedoglake
daily coast and of course our own
Michigan liberal calm and she has an
incredible story to tell and an
incredible book that you will want to
buy at the end of the tonight so without
further ado Marcy wheeler thanks and
thanks everyone for coming out this is
really cool because I haven't been doing
a whole bunch of book events and it's
every time I come out to one it's like
wow people so I'm going to talk a little
bit about both how the how am I writing
on this story came about how the book
came about how vastra media came about
and how live blogging the scooter libby
trial came about and hopefully won't
take too long and put anyone to sleep
and then afterwards every time i do
these things people have lots of very
interesting questions so I want to leave
some time for questions as most of you I
think know the book came out of the
blogging that I started doing it next to
raw and I I wrote the book and I started
the blogging because first of all Judy
Miller was about to go to jail and
everyone in the meeting was like oh my
god Judy Miller was going to jail and I
was like you know what if she's entirely
complicit and protecting scooter libby
and at the beginning people thought I
was crazy I got in a big fight with
meteor blades if anybody knows meteor
blades the blogger and he kept saying
you know First Amendment protect the
journalists and I was like PR flack for
the administration you would not give
the PR flack for Enron firstman you know
reporters privilege so why should we
give Judy Miller and so I did this
series on Judy Miller and among all of
the other things that I discovered about
her reporting from Iraq I also
discovered that she insinuated at the
very least that one of ama Chavez big
rivals was a CIA asset and I thought
that was pretty interesting that she did
that a mere month and a half before the
administration tried to launder the leak
of Valerie Plame's identity to her and
when
kind of brought that out people are like
well yeah maybe there is a continuity
between what Judy Miller was doing in
Iraq and what you know she was then what
they tried to make her do when she got
back to the states and then after I
finished that series this was right when
the news came out the car Rove was the
source for Matt Cooper the day that it
was reported that Karl Rove was also a
source for Robert Novak all of a sudden
I don't know if you guys remember this
all of a sudden there was this big
campaign where all of the stories about
Valerie Plame you'd think they would be
about rope but they weren't they were
about Ari Fleischer with the INR memo
above you know a board Air Force to
which was a completely bogus story and
clearly invented by robe and the media
bought it hook line and sinker and I was
like this is crazy so I kept writing and
kept writing and that's how I got stuck
on the story and really obsessed and for
those of you who followed along on next
door I you know that I became quite the
obsessed person and read every single
filing they came out of there and but
that was fun and then I about it well
not quite a year ago at yearly coast so
the first yearly coast convention jane
hampshire put together a panel with
myself and her and Christie Christie
harden smith and joe wilson and larry
johnson and we had about 10 people up on
that stage or something like that but
over the course of the weekend I was
like you know Jane I think I've got a
book and jane jane hampshire for those
of you who don't know was my publisher
also was the producer for natural born
killers and some other hollywood movie
so as soon as you put a good idea in her
head you all of a sudden see things go
to you know start to work and and she
starts making things happen so you know
before i knew it she's like okay we're
going to do a book and it was like oh
okay well that happened and that the
idea behind vaster media came about
because some of you may be familiar with
marcos melissa syndrome Armstead
Armstrong's crashing the gates which was
based on what they were doing in their
blogs but also based on a lot of what
they were recording on their blogs and
they did that really quickly I mean they
kind of went in camps with the same
editor who did my book camped out with
him in Montana and wrote it in very
quick time and turn
it into a book and and that's how that
came about Glenn Greenwald's how would a
patriot act same a lot of the same
people involved same process we're going
to go camp out write a book in an
obscenely short amount of time and as a
result it's going to be a very very
timely book and by the time I came
around and said I think I have a book
they're like hey we've got a business
model you know we can continue doing
these obscene production schedules and
and and have a book that way so we
actually did the outline for the book
the first week of october two thousand
six i turned in the draft or we turned
in everything december one that's how
long it took me to write the book
luckily i mean that's the benefit the
ideas you've got i had like thirty five
thousand words written and blog posts
just on the main series that i had done
so i was like well i just have to
rewrite it for humans who don't read my
blog which was actually took a lot of
doing they're like you know people don't
know any of these acronyms i'm like
people don't know what the end i use
their likeness start start somewhere
else you know and so yeah so we wrote it
in two months basically and a lot of
people went through some big hoops but
that's going to be I mean keep your eye
out for vaster media for vaster books
because i think the official launch is
going to be this year's yearly coast
convention which will be in august and i
think i know of for people who are going
to have titles coming out all on some
really interesting subjects and all some
of the best people in the blogosphere
with some really interesting things to
say and I mean the idea behind it is I
mean first of all to have timely books
from people who are really engaging with
both their subjects and their readers on
a day-to-day basis and to reach out to
people who otherwise wouldn't read this
stuff I mean I've got people who don't
even have computers they've come up and
like I loved the book I was like wow you
would never have found my blog then I
guess and then one of the other things
now will make my pitch for drinking
liberally but one of the other things
that we're trying to do is is to market
it with via different channels you know
drinking liberally is a great
organization you can get people to come
out in large numbers and drink and then
they won't you know notice that they
just bought a book and had you sign
so so we did I did a drinking liberally
event in New York and a drinking
liberally event in Washington DC and
they were both a lot of fun so and then
the questions get interesting because
you know by the time i get done talking
you guys will it be on your third beer
and then then the liveblogs started and
again this was this was a lot largely
due to jane into kristy from firedoglake
but I you know about II about a year ago
we were kind of like well gosh there's
going to be a trial at the end of this
and we ought to be there and Jane and
Christy started nine months before the
trial trying to get a pass and the
courthouse was kind of like fire what
and so then they went to Ariana and said
you're famous you get us a path and so
Ariana went to work now like Ariana do
you run a blog but we kept going and
then there was this kind of right wing
nut case he was also working on getting
bloggers passes by the time I came like
Marcos and Jane were in New York City
one day about the day before the
deadline forgetting the passes was about
to about to expire Jen called me up
she's like hey Marco says you should get
a pass for dailykos like great winsa
deadly she's like two o'clock like she's
like so what you gotta do is you gotta
invent some daily co stationery and send
a letter from Marcos saying that you get
a press pass is like sure why not and I
was just like here's all of the things
I've ever written on flame trust me I
should be at this trial sure enough i
got in i was like whew that was you know
i suck heard somebody put them there
there were people in the courthouse uh
we have reason to believe certainly
after the trial started who are
following along and loving it but we
think we had an advocate or two in the
courthouse to so that helped that people
knew what the blogs were a knew that we
weren't kind of crazy people and so the
way the live blogging worked was that
there was we were there were I think
altogether six bloggers who six six
passes assigned to bloggers for the
trial we were the only bloggers that had
a courtroom past
which was kind of cool because you know
you want it we had Christie artsmith is
used to be a state prosecutor we had
Geralyn merican on our past she said she
was on the maquette McVeigh defense team
so she knows her way around a courtroom
and and Jane of course knows her way
around drama as well as anybody and then
patch acoutic who's also on firedoglake
is a shrink so we had this great team to
put them in the courtroom I didn't make
it into the courtroom until the very
last day because i was like no I'm
having so much fun at the computer don't
let me go you know so they had that they
had the actual courtroom where you
couldn't bring in fun stuff like your
computer but then they had a closer
closer fit TV of what was going on in
the in the courtroom itself and you
could see the attorneys the judge and
the defense table couldn't see the
jurors so I could see everything but the
jurors but also I was there with the
mainstream media so I was there as they
were watching kathy martin say Oh Dick
Cheney says that when we go on Tim
russets show we control the message and
I was on there when they were going when
Judy Miller and ten other journalists
got up and said well I don't really take
notes and I really can't tell you what
off the record means and I can't really
tell you you know and that you know the
journalists and in the media room going
well yeah of course off the record
doesn't mean the same thing two
different people we all know that it
means different things I was like okay
that's interesting they're like but this
is off the record too so you can't
publish this but so it was it was a very
angst-ridden media room it was very
interesting seeing what you know what
they were trying to get into their
stories that that was being cut by their
editors and hearing some like NBC had I
mean they were the main angst people
after New York Times on this story and
and hearing their angst and hearing
their squabbling amongst themselves so
it was a really interesting process one
of the things I discovered and this is I
mean a lot of people like asking
questions about this but one of the
things that I I just you know it was
really fascinating to see what we
thought was worthy of coverage and what
the mainstream media thought was worthy
of coverage and just one example which
is my favorite story julie lynn will
make
make me tell her favorite story but my
favorite story from the trial was I'm
sitting there live blogging and this was
one of Fitzgerald's maybe five most
brilliant moments from the trial Craig
small is the CIA briefer for the vice
president for actually for scooter libby
but also for the vice president and he
says okay what two things do you
remember from June of 2003 that you
brief scooter libby on he said well I
only remember two things he's like okay
what were the two and he says one was
that both of them came back and
complained to me that somebody at the
CIA was talking to the press about
twisting their arms I was like oh that
was good that you got that in there
wasn't that Fitzgerald and he's like
what was the other one he's like oh well
it was that scooter libby made time to
talk to Tom Cruise about how badly
Germany treats Scientologists and you
know the whole like scooter Libby's
whole story right was that he was so
busy making sure that he got a rack
right that he didn't have time to
remember that he outed a CIA knock and I
was like Tom Cruise if you're making
time for Tom Cruise your whole story
goes out the window and you know that
the journalists really love it like Tom
Cruise I can actually get something on
the front page you know Tom Cruise my
editor will love it six people the next
day one after another were like my
editor cut Tom Cruise my editor cut Tom
Cruise my editor cod Tom Cruise and the
reason is differed from person to person
but nevertheless to me that's something
that we ought to know we ought to know
that the vice president's top security
person thinks it's worthwhile to spend
time learning about Tom Tom Cruise's
little angst but apparently the editors
of this country don't think that's very
important so that's that's my favorite
little story i'm sure i'm forgetting
others but the way we're going to do
questions so that c-span can get the
questions is that if you want to ask a
question raise your hand and then
they've got a boom mic so that you'll
actually get to be on TV too so you need
to wait for the new mic to come over to
you so anybody want to start with
questions oh julie lynn of course you're
going to make me tough I don't
remember the story can you tell us a
little bit about the mainstream media
can you tell us a funny story or two
from the mainstream media that you
encountered while you were there like
what oh here's some good news for
Michigan people by the way David
Schuster's phone rings with hail to the
victor I shouldn't tell that stir oh
shoot I forgot where I was I know
there's at least one other Wolverine in
the room no actually was you know it was
all supposed to be off the record David
corn actually allowed me to use his name
there there were other people like I
made one reference just to somebody and
he liked it was actually pretty funny
because Schuster followed along because
he loves firedoglake so he was following
like he was watching with me but
watching me live blog he was sitting
right behind me kind of fighting he's
like one day when when John Hannah who
is one of the big neo-cons when he
testified normally i was using people's
initials so it should have been JH and
on that day he had just made this really
ridiculous comment about Iran and he
said oh you know 2007 is going to be the
year of Iran so instead of calling him
JH I called him the year of Iran and
within minutes after I first updated
Schuster was like what is this you're on
the wrong thing I was like to get people
like yours attention so I want your
story today to be all about around he's
like okay and he came back the next day
he's like we did around all day I was
like cool but so one day she sure was up
in the courtroom and all of a sudden I
hear this funk off did you did it and
everyone the media rooms going hose is
that whose is that him like I knows cuz
I somebody in Michigan told me that he's
got helped the vicar's in his phone and
so it went off again and it went off at
a critical period so we couldn't
actually hear what was going on and
schuster came back and he's like I was
like shoe strat I saved you man you're
lucky I'm a Wolverine because they were
all gonna throw your phone out
and many found out that I actually put
in a live blog and he's a little bit i
think i know what about that sorry david
shuster I didn't mean to do that but
couldn't help myself there's another
store you want me to tell julie lynn but
i forget what it is oh well before i
actually get down there we had something
to do here in michigan and so during the
week of jury selection i did a report
card of the media of the coverage of the
median so i made up it was basically a
through f and but i came up with some
better names for a through f and you
know i just i graded them I remember
Carol leonid was top somebody who
wouldn't want me to mention his name was
second and at the very bottom that the
second one was this reporter who emailed
me immediately and he said why didn't I
get an A and I was like well because
this detail you have absolutely no proof
for and he's like and he tried to like
be arrogant with me and he's like I can
point you to where in the court filings
it is and where in the yada yada it is
and I was like look unless it was in
December 19 searing you don't have any
evidence for that claim and you should
you deserve a B and he was like he just
didn't he assumed I had not done the
homework I was like no unless of us so
he was really worried and then and I
said and oh by the way how come you
haven't been reporting on what has also
come out in court filings which is that
Robert Novak and scooter libby had a
meeting that they've been hiding for
three years why is nobody in the
mainstream media reporting them he's
like uh talk to me when you get to DC so
anyway that was one person then there
was the New York Times story which was
basically i don't i don't know if
anybody knows who Barbara Comstock is
but she used to be in charge of PR for
the Justice Department under Ashcroft
and then went into being scooter Libby's
full-time PR person which is you know
already kind of a conflict of interest
but I guess that doesn't bother the
people on the right and she she was in
the courtroom and she for journalists
who weren't following along the story
very well or who didn't feel like doing
a lot of work she would just land
something in their lap and they would
poured it right away that's how the
stories like Ari Fleischer stories get
going but she had landed this very nice
profile into the lap of somebody at the
New York Times and you know I gave him
enough and I said that he this is
probably going to get bleeped out on
c-span but I said that he had given
scooter libby a [ __ ] and this was
from the New York Times and you know the
New York Times has a certain certain
sensitivity or fondness i think i think
i actually started where I said you know
time was when New York Times thought you
know a [ __ ] was an impeachable
offense now they seem to think it's the
appropriate thing to do to somebody's
about to be you know convicted of a
felony three weeks later the same
journalist got me and Jane and swollen
and our coverage on the front page of
the New York Times that much above the
fold I was like there's this weird
masochism on the part of a lot of
mainstream media where they like you
call him out and you say that was that
was nice you know wait for lip no um and
and they then they're like oh I gotta be
nice to you now I got it I gotta be good
to you now so that worked like a charm
and for those of you who blog I've been
pushing this for a long time and haven't
done a report card sense but I really
think that the blogosphere needs to get
into report cards better because then
you're not just saying your coverage
stunk you're saying your coverage stunk
but Karoly onyx was great or this person
from you know well Cara Lee onyx was
great you know and and then they're
competing with each other and I think
that really has you know whatever you're
appealing to their to their worst sense
of ego so so that works any other
questions yeah
why kind of still like Jason leopold and
i think is it mark ash yeah ever okay
however what's your opinion I there was
something a couple weeks ago and I
forget what it was but what's your
opinion about sealed versus sealed I
don't have the numbers um I have been
told a that that particular sealed
versus sealed you know I don't know this
for a fact but I've been I've been given
another explanation for that particular
sealed versus sealed that has nothing
that had to do with firedoglake given
with fire done with scooter libby with
plane and it comes from a pretty
reliable source so you know and then
i've heard another explanation for that
sealed versus yield but I at this point
I don't see any reason to believe that
it has anything to do with plane I
really don't I mean I don't see who
could still have a sealed indictment
does everyone know what the sealed
versus sealed refers to back when Karl
Rove when it seemed like Karl Rove is
about to get indicted there were reports
that he in fact was indicted or came
close to being indicted and just about
the same time that that happened there
was what's called a sealed versus sealed
indictment that was entered into the
docket in DC so it's a court case that
could be Joe Smith versus I mean the US
government versus Joe Smith it could be
Joe Smith versus the US government it
could be the US government versus Karl
Rove it could be anything they usually
use sealed versus sealed in cases where
they're trying when they're when they're
investigating kind of mobsters or drug
networks or you know they've got one guy
who's made a plea deal and they seal his
indictment until he brings down the
kingpins and so the idea was they were
sealing Rove's indictment until
something happened and I just I've heard
too many other plausible excuses and you
know I kind of believe Fitzgerald when
he said as far as i know i don't expect
anything further until i get more
evidence so that's not a direct quote
from what he said but that's close
about Rove I'm not very hopeful about
rove i think that rove and i say this in
the book one is I think if Fitzgerald
wanted to take a case against Rove he
would be relying on the testimony of
Richard Armitage who also forgot whether
purposely or not a conversation with the
journalist earlier and he'd be relying
on the purpose on the testimony I think
of ari fleischer who I suspect was being
directed by Karl Rove to say certain
things during the during I mean one of
the one of the interesting things that
came out during the trial was Libby's
lawyers were going for they want to know
what kind of proffer Ari Fleischer made
to get immunity and he said basically re
didn't say anything about Libby it
sounded like re said something about
somebody else and the obvious candidate
would be Rove because already worked a
lot closer with Rove than he did with
Libby but but you would rely on Ari
Fleischer who also leaked and also you
know are like you got to have some
credible witness to be able to take a
case against Karl Rove and I suspect
that although there's abundant evidence
that Karl Rove his story doesn't make
any sense that doesn't mean that you can
indict him for it and that's just the
way the justice system works the
unfortunate thing is the way the press
in this in this country works he got
away with in the press to you know so I
think at this point the most likely
thing to happen is he gets indicted on a
neighbor moth charge he gets indicted on
something having to do with the US
Attorney scandal or he gets he loses a
security clearance and loses his job but
that'll probably happen about six weeks
before the end of the administration so
sorry I wish I could be more optimistic
lam information to arbitration sarma
touch armored suits got the information
from what's called the inr memo so he
and that i do believe i mean actually he
got it he got it verbally from mark
Grossman and then got it from the eye on
our memo but i think and and this is
this is my completely speculative theory
that that at the very least
Carl when when when Robert Novak came in
and talked to Richard Armitage she came
in and he said you know Joe Wilson never
worked at the CIA so why was he sent and
this is what Novak says this is what you
know this is what he says he said to
Richard to Richard Armitage if I asked
any of you in the room how you would go
about proving that Joe Wilson ever
worked at the CIA how would you do that
you know and and I mean more especially
because Joe Wilson has the kind of
resume that somebody who was under
official cover might have had I mean a
lot of the jobs he had early in his
career were the kind of counselor jobs
that that people who are under official
cover so you I mean just looking at his
resume you would never be able to say he
never worked for the CIA so you know
I've long suggested there's probably a
good chance that somebody went to know
back and said hey you know don't know
Joe Wilson never worked for the CIA go
figure out why he got sent similarly
when Woodward came to armitage Woodward
said I know who the then still
classified ambassador was who got sent
to New share again he could have found
that out from Pincus by then he could
have found that out from his own
reporting he also could have found that
out in a jet and a June to meeting he
had with scooter libby so I think
there's the other thing that and this is
something that isn't in the book because
they came out at the trial but the other
thing and this is this is going to be
kind of weedy so I apologize in advance
but there are two big time Republican
donors and lobbyists who fall into the
story and and it's not really clear what
their role was but one's name is do
burstyn gooberstein was the guy who got
a meeting between Novak and armitage
even though Armitage had been refusing
to meet with no act for years and years
and years duper son came to armitage and
said you gotta meet with this guy so he
set up the meeting between Novak and
armitage and then later in the fall
after this became an investigation he
went to Novak and said Oh Armitage
didn't really think he leaps he didn't
do it on purpose you know I which is
like obstruction much you know you don't
you don't go to the journalists who got
the illegal leak and said here let me
give you a script this is what our
metouch believes he did that's what this
guy do bruh stunted there's another guy
holt and holds at the beginning of the
week during league week went to rove and
went to Novak and said you should you
should do this story and then later in
the week he got a copy of the story from
from Novak and gave it to the White
House before it was on the wires before
was anywhere else well these two guys
doober stein and holt are part of a club
called off the record club and if you
look at some of the other coverage some
of the other members of the club are the
ones who are always out there going oh
scooter libby should be pardoned scooter
libby should be you know beatified
scooter libby should you know be paid
six times the pension for taking the
fall for dick cheney and and and it
really looks like these two Republican
lobbyist donors brokered the leak I mean
they clearly they were they set up the
meeting with between armitage and Novak
they made sure the White House got got
the article at the end they made sure
they were involved in whatever cover up
there was in fall 2003 and that's
something that I think is worth you know
is interesting worth looking into I'd
love to see more on that I'd love to
find out more about the way in which the
White House launders their leaks between
these you know through these you know
rich lobbyists types but it's kind of
kind of interesting any other questions
yet there's oh and there's one in the
back to them go head first off I'm
curious if you think any of the emails
that that the RNC doesn't want to give
over to the Congress and don't talk
about that um guys I ain't it yeah um I
my best guess is no and I you know I
have asked Fitzgerald spokesperson about
this and and he won't tell um he's a
very nice guy
he's also brilliant and not telling you
anything useful but but if you look at
the timing what we know does it the
emails that she's referring to have
become public for a variety of reasons
recently one is that Rove and his deputy
this guy Scott Jennings have been
setting up these part like that they're
going on to government property and
doing these powerpoints saying these are
the Republicans that were worried about
these are the Democrats were going to
take out in 2008 which is a violation of
the Hatch Act the emails discussing
these were not sent from the White House
they were sent on a republican national
one of the RNC um server or george w
bush 43 is the email domain name so
that's one another one is Abramoff was
using it abramoff kind of toady inside
the White House by the name of Susan
Ralston like gleefully said oh I've got
this great RNC email now mail me there
or black marry me on my RNC blackberry
there's no security issues so basically
you know if you want to break the law do
it on the RNC server and then there's a
then there's the third one which is some
of these some of the emails surrounding
the the US Attorney scandal also have
been sent in the RNC server so that the
rule is if you want to do something
nefarious you do it on their servers but
if you look at the timeline the RNC
first started saving White House emails
in august of 2004 and I suspect that's
earlier than Fitzgerald got to them I
suspect that that hold had to do with
the abramoff investigation because if
you look at if you look at Susan
Ralston's emails that have been printed
off their printed off and in May 2004 so
by May it was clear she was using it but
it would also explain why somebody in
the RNC put a hold on everything in the
white house except for robes emails and
then you know because rogue has a little
bit of pull in the RNC and then it's
2005 some time and I've heard October of
2005 wear robes emails were actually
saved
and that's the time when Fitzgerald was
really chasing down some more of these
emails so I think what I think what
happened with Fitzgerald is when when
Rove's attorney kind of invented this
email as the explanation for how row of
all of a sudden remembered that he had
leaked to Matt Cooper even though he'd
forgotten for two years when you know
under oath five times that I think I
think Fitzgerald really did the
investigation on those emails closer to
October of 2005 and that's so I think
that he did get them but that's my best
guess I'm not working with any it would
make sense let me go to the back first
time we'll talk to you I just wonder if
you have any thoughts on why the
mainstream media has been so willing to
lap up whatever they've been fed by this
administration by this administration
mean I think the the way they enforce
access and this administration is really
tough because you know they they will
shut you off if you don't tow their line
and they will mean like I don't know I
mentioned Barbra comstock earlier but
there's a journalist Eric lick blow he's
one of the good ones New York Times he's
one of the two guys who broke the NSA
wiretap story he was actually
blackballed at Department of Justice
he's he's the new york times department
of justice reporter and they blackballed
him you know and if if this
administration is willing to blackball
in New York Times reporter that's saying
something about the discipline they're
using but the other thing is that and
when I have discussions I mean like I
said one of the most interesting things
about covering the trial was being with
all these journalists and having these
endless discussions about reporting and
reporters have really gotten to the
point where it's not a story for them
unless they have a source to confirm it
so when you go back I said that there
was there were court filing starting in
October of last year that scooter libby
and novak had spoken the you know as it
turns out the week of the leak as it
turns out before the novak article was
written as it turns out there are ovp
talking points in the middle of his
column so
no that Novak used stuff from Libby and
I you know I I've asked so many
journalists why are you not covering
this and it's I think the answer to that
quite simply is because neither Novak
nor Libby is talking about it so they
don't have any source for it and if you
know it's kind of like if a bear poops
in the woods does any and nobody's there
do you if a leak happens and nobody's
willing to source it did it really
happen according to the mainstream media
know and so for the stuff that they're
not getting sources for they can't tell
the story and they're desperate to
retain those sources so I mean it's
really access it really is i think may
not that i don't know and and the fact
this is another this is another one of
my favorite stories so gonna bare with
me um i was talking to one of the
journalists whom marie wass who was a
great journalists on this story he said
oh these people are really good one of
the guys that he has a lot of respect
for thinks is really good he's you know
he does a little bit of research so he's
not a bad journalist but we sat down one
day and we were talking about this kind
of ridiculous story that's good early be
told about being authorized to leak the
NIE to judy miller and i said that story
doesn't make any sense and he said well
but that's what i was told i was like no
but it's not logically possible so he
kind of blew that up as did every single
reporter covering this story I mean I I
know for a fact that the jury got the
NIE story and they're like bogus this
doesn't make any sense but the reporters
were like but that's what we were told
so it's got to be true and then the same
journalist who you know that i was
talking to who was okay that it didn't
make logical sense then I said well you
know you're attributing the the
remaining parts of Novak's story to
novaks story but his story has changed
five times litter I mean literally I've
traced it it strange five times trust me
on this I was like so which story of his
are you believing and why are you
crediting somebody whose story has
changed five times and he looked at me
this is a good reporter remember he
looked at me he said
you're making my head hurt yeah so
there's a lot of that going on too let's
come up here and then going back we're
all aware that the central core of a
democracy is information and a free
press and I've noticed of late that it
seems to be that well with the
consolidation of allowing fewer hands to
have control corporate control of the
media outlet as well as in our local
paper when when President Bush happened
to mention that he finally admitted that
there was no connection between Saddam
Hussein in Iraq and 911 that appeared on
page six below the fold in our paper if
you look at our front pages at least in
our front page and I think in so many
papers that you find that they've put
nothing but entertainment in fluff and
there seems to be an attempt to dumb
down the American public and to keep
them from actually knowing what's going
on in the governor and it seems to be
more than just government it seems to be
in conjunction with the media so the
question I have and also the internet I
think they're trying to get a handle on
the internet so that they can restrict
free flow of information so the question
I have is since you work in the media do
you feel that the media has become
conscripted or co-opted by the the
government and the power and is it all
one group which is trying to manipulate
and control access and information for
the benefit of corporate america the and
the small number of people who control
this country I think there's a lot I
mean there's not just one thing it's not
as easy as saying well NBC is owned by
General Electric so they need to justify
dropping more bombs you can argue that
at very high levels for NBC and you can
argue certainly there their fondness for
status quo as well
their fondness for the profit I mean the
the profits that they're asking
newspapers to make these days are absurd
there's no way a newspaper should be
asked to make twenty percent profit so I
mean those two things are happening a
lot of it you know editors are a lot
more conservative than the reporters who
are covering these things a lot of it is
this kind of mistaken belief that people
don't want to know about the world
they're living in and a lot of it is
really that journalists I mean one of
the things that I developed some
sympathy for journalists as you know I
was live blogging so I just updated
every 15 minutes or every time Tom
Cruise came up and I didn't have to then
try and boil it down into something
intelligent until later in the day
usually I'd do a post first thing in the
morning and the whoever was in the
courtroom would be being the
intelligence you know they would do the
wrap-up host and they'd have to be the
smart people but the the bigger media
outlets were on to a day deadlines so
that meant that they had two people one
person was in the media room working on
the story for the lunch time deadline
and the other person was upstairs in the
courtroom and they'd come down in the
afternoon they'd be working on the the
story for the deadline for the afternoon
and it just was a stupid schedule I mean
it was just not not a way to understand
both the details and the big picture and
it was very artificial was like we have
to have one in exactly one story from
the scooter libby trial every day you
know and so if you want to talk about
Tom Cruise and you want to talk about
kathy martin and the way in which tim
russert dick cheney control system
records show you couldn't do it those
more to you know you couldn't do two
stories you had to bury them into one
which is one of the ways in which Tom
Cruise gets cut so and I just think I
mean there were there were there were
some very diligent very good reporters
in that room who because of the the way
in which they're being asked to work
threats they just can't do is go to work
is they're clearly capable of so you
know I think I don't think there's a
cabal that's making all these decisions
although clearly you know the
republicans are working with fox news
and so long so long as I mean now that
Democrats are refusing to show up on fox
news I think CNN and MSNBC are going to
think twice about trying to be Fox News
light you know because there is still
some of that competition going on and I
mean this goes back to to the you know
to grading the reporters oh you know
some of the reporters think I'm I'm
weird you know when I was in the when I
was in the in the media room some of
them were surprised how hard I worked
and one of them came up afterwards and
he's like I thought you guys just SAT
there and gave commentary and but you
worked I'm like remember how I told you
I read every single trial filing I did
you know it takes a lot of time and then
some of them you know some of them were
just were really nice to us but um but
you know it's a it's they especially are
watching us okay one more story about
this there was one day where I'm at the
MSNBC people and some other people other
nut Shuster because he was upstairs and
um they were talking about like dying to
get column inches and fighting within
their own organizations to get column
inches and what they would do to get
that kind of attention and that kind of
and and somebody said there was a
Bloomberg reporter in the room and
somebody said I don't know how Bloomberg
mates makes money Bloomberg charges
eighteen hundred dollars a month for a
subscription to Bloomberg and I Eileen
you know the Bloomberg I was a really
nice guy was sitting right next to me
and I said well it's because you charge
an exorbitant amount every month and
he's like a two hundred dollars I'm like
now one who you guys are making money
but he and I were having this kind of
funny discussion about like still being
a viable media outlet and everybody else
was in the back of the room going oh you
know they're desperate for to cling to
the last crumbs of dying media outlets
and so I think that there's this
masochism on the part of some people in
the media because they they see that
we're being successful the blogs are
successful and that Bloomberg is
successful and they
I want to understand what we've got that
they don't have and so there is kind of
this masochism to their dues yeah isn't
Fox News an oxymoron oh yeah Fox
Entertainment although I mean although
there was a rewrite ok one more astute
one of the reporters who covered for the
trial for Fox News actually was really
nice and and not a complete crazy person
but the other story about Fox News is
Fox News and this gets rate to your
point Fox News at one point which came
first they were filming something
outside of the courthouse and there were
courthouse employees trying to get
something set up for whatever they were
filming so they were doing their job
their civil servants they were the event
they were about setting up the event and
fox news came up and they said you got
to move over you gotta move over live TV
crew and they were like but you don't
have an event unless you know they just
pushed you know so it was so typical
like they just pushed them aside so then
the next day I was not in the courthouse
and guess who stole my seat so I was
joking around a lot about Fox News
stealing everyones seat but they really
believe that they're the story you know
they really believe that they don't need
the civil servants who who are about
justice because they'll just push
somebody aside you know they're the
story now so that's what they think they
are and that's how they get to be
entertainment truly lens pointing at her
watch but somebody had a question back
there that I want to make sure we get to
I just wondered uh aren't the media a
lot of them i'm not going to condemn
them all but aren't a lot of them just
plain lazy and it and it's easy for them
to just all pile on and do the same
stories or to do to act like a bunch of
piranhas and they go for the blood in
the water kind of thing and and and you
know just strip any particular story
right down to the bone I'm sort of
thinking of national Geographics recent
program on fresh water and the piranhas
but it the journalists remind me of that
and print in their coverage of any story
I mean pick a story picking out the
recent of Virginia Tech
incident but aren't they really a lot of
them they're just they're lazy and they
aren't willing to do the real work like
like was done during Watergate to to
truly uncover and and reveal the kinds
of information that people should be
made aware of I think that's true of a
lot of them it's not it's definitely not
true of all of them but it's also true I
mean it's you know it's amazing how the
narrative I mean again being in the
media room was very fascinating because
you know I'd be typing the whole time
because I was live blogging but when
something exciting happened you'd hear
everyone start typing at the same time
and then at the next lull in
conversation they'd all go ok exactly
what's the quote and they don't compare
notes what's the quote what's a quote
what's a quote and as often as not it
wasn't the person who was typing that
people listen to it was the person who
was loudest sir kind of the you know the
biggest pushy guy or whatever and so and
so you literally saw the narrative
getting in the words getting set with
that kind of pack mentality but there
were you know 10 people in the meeting
room who were ignoring everybody else
and getting the quote for themselves and
trying to do it that way so I just think
and on the plane story I mean Maria wass
has done great work Carolee Oneg did
really great work I suspect she could
have done better work if I mean I
suspect that she had better work that
got cut and The Washington Post in
general I thought the Washington Post
news side in general covered this very
well he had a twirl side then undid all
of what their news i did and did ten
times more damage and there were five or
six other people in the in the media who
were covering this story well and then
the rest did whatever Cara whatever
Barbra comstock told them so you know
partly that's that they weren't covering
it full-time partly it's a resource
issue you know that they don't I covered
this story for two years not many of the
people who were covering it at the trial
had covered it for two years Carolee
onek was one of the exceptions Marie
wass was probably the other so
I think you know there's a lot of I mean
the same answer that I gave before I
think there's a lot of different reasons
for why the media isn't working and we
need to remember that there are all
these different reasons going on as I
understand it sy Hersh got interviewed
by somebody cool today or yesterday and
in it he was asked similar kinds of
questions I hirsch said basically you
need to fire every single top level
executive and editor everywhere and just
let the reporters take over and you're
going to see good reporting again and I
think that's largely true but you'd also
have to take out the twenty percent
profit requirement